[Music]
hi guys it's quint here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
scientists believe
that at some point during human history
the population had been reduced to just
1 000 reproductive adults
in the year 70 000 bc
humans almost entirely vanished from the
face of the planet itself
according to scientists near extinction
has occurred at least three times over
the course of humanity's 100 000 year
history
the dilution of mankind to so few humans
magnifies the impact of all human
actions
in lucian's remembrance of earth's past
trilogy humanity is tested many times
but there is no single greater
near-extinction event than the singer's
dimension strike
we've discussed the crisis era the
deterrence era the post-deterrence era
in this video we will discuss the
broadcast era the era directly following
the crew of gravity and blue space's
decision to activate the universal
broadcast system freeing the human race
from tricelerian oppression while
inadvertently revealing the location of
the earth to the inhabitants of the dark
forest
and the bunker era which followed the
return of tian ming whose brain had been
sent off into the vacuum of space
centuries earlier
trisolaris had already met its fate
after its location was revealed to the
dark forest
the world and all its inhabitants had
been annihilated save the trisolerin
fleet who escaped into deep space
humanity had known that the earth was
doomed but something gave them hope that
survival was possible
the cryptic stories of young tianming
young tyangming's return to our solar
system would seem as the arrival of an
angel of salvation to the remaining
humans on earth to understand who
tianming is his direct tied to the sword
holder changzin and how these events
came to be we have to go back to a long
forgotten program enacted during the
crisis era the staircase project
part one
the staircase project
in the eyes of historians the staircase
project was a typical result of the
ill-thought-out impulsiveness that
marked the beginning of the crisis era a
hastily conducted poorly planned
adventure in addition to the complete
failure to accomplish its objectives it
left nothing of technological value
the space technology that eventually
developed took a completely different
direction no one could have predicted
that nearly three centuries later the
staircase project would bring a ray of
hope to an earth mired in despair
during the crisis era humanity made
leaps and bounds in terms of innovation
and technological progress
even with trisolaran sofa and stifling
them the staircase project was first
viewed as a waste of resources
later as a source of hope but by
examining the text we see that it was in
fact a dire mistake on the part of
humanity
no one ever discovered exactly how the
tricelerans intercepted and captured the
probe carrying tiaming's brain but it is
revealed that this is what ultimately
gave the aliens the upper hand against
humanity
during the deterrence era
tianming himself had designed the
droplet attack against humanity
the spin-off book redemption of time
goes into detail about what happened to
tianming during his time among the
trisillerins wonders horrors and all we
will definitely discuss redemption of
time in its own video at some point in
the future as it was approved by
loshishan but not considered an official
part of the canon by some
the staircase project had been enacted
around the same time that luo g became a
wall facer
the original goal of the staircase
project had been to launch a human
toward the trisolaren fleet at one
percent the speed of light that person
could serve as a diplomat between the
two worlds while also gathering
intelligence shenzhen had been an
engineer working for the project
thomas wade who led the project
eventually decided that based on the
assumption that the tricelerians could
in fact regenerate the body it would be
better to find someone to euthanize and
send only their brain
at the time xian ming was terminally ill
xiang zhing convinced him to volunteer
for the program
the book acknowledges that this project
was foolish but it's meant to reflect
the many foolish things that humans have
done throughout time which are only seen
in a clearer light through the lens of
history even if their plan had initially
gone as expected once tianming's brain
actually approached the tricelerins it
was bound to go wrong but of course the
initial portion of the plan didn't even
go well
when the probe is launched there is a
malfunction tianming's brain is launched
off course into deep space
seemingly lost forever
one of the cables holding the sail to
the staircase probe had broken near the
orbit of jupiter
the craft had deviated from its planned
path and the earth deprived of its
flight parameters lost it to the endless
depths of space
if the tricelerians had been able to
intercept it later they must have had
its flight parameters after the cable
broke
otherwise even the advanced tricelerin
technology would have been incapable of
locating such a small object in the
vastness of space outside the solar
system the most likely explanation was
that the sophons had followed the
staircase project probe at least through
its acceleration leg
to gather its final parameters
part two
the return of ming
during the broadcast era following the
destruction of trisolaris the remnants
of the trisolarens reveal to humanity
that they have young tianming in their
custody
apparently the tricelerians had treated
him like an honored guest they had given
him this final opportunity to speak with
xiangzin who he had been infatuated with
for many years before leaving earth
but in truth this was tian ming's
opportunity to attempt to save humanity
from destruction
the trisalaran's knew several secrets of
the universe which humanity did not but
they had no interest in humans learning
those secrets
the communication between tian ming and
xiangzin was heavily monitored by the
tricelerians so tian ming provides his
secrets through the use of multi-layered
fairy tales this was the only way he was
able to avoid alerting the trisolarens
to what he was doing
one day in a special video we might go
into the specific details of tianming's
stories but for the purposes of keeping
this video flowing i'll just sum up the
relevant information that was gathered
from those stories as the tales
themselves are quite lengthy and complex
the secrets he reveals essentially boil
down to a single truth there is in fact
a way for a civilization to survive in
the dark forest
humanity worked extremely hard to
decipher his stories but they never
fully managed to
the stories revealed that light speed
could actually be attained through
curvature propulsion
which would allow the warping of space
the other key secret humanity managed to
reveal was that it was possible for a
civilization to reduce the speed of
light in a specific area of space
this would make it so that they could
never escape their own star system they
would exist within a black domain having
no effect on the space outside
to the outside universe it would appear
as a moat of darkness floating amongst
infinite darkness
the idea of building light speed ships
intended to allow escape from the solar
system brought up the same issues as
escapism did earlier during the crisis
era
not everyone would be allowed to escape
likely only the ultra wealthy would be
allowed to flee the solar system
venturing out into the cosmos while the
rest of them awaited death the populace
heavily resented this idea and
eventually all research into curvature
propulsion was banned
shangzin realized that this decision may
doom humanity and in her guilt for
allowing deterrence to be destroyed she
gives away her personal wealth to thomas
wade who assembling a team was to
continue to develop the technology in
secret
as time continues earth is mostly
evacuated humanity invests heavily in
space cities the artificial light
sources could hide in the shadow of
jupiter and saturn and potentially
escape any photoid attack now they could
only wait
xiang goes into hibernation for another
60 years and is only awakened after wade
gets into a standoff with the government
wade has continued to develop curvature
repulsion technology and has now
produced an anti-matter weapon which the
government saw as an immense danger
once awakened xiangzhin demands that he
stand down
the government shows no mercy to wade he
is executed a depressed shangzin decides
to return to hibernation she knows that
this is twilight for humanity the final
hours when she was awakened again
another 60 years later the long-awaited
attack was underway if it had been a
photoid then humanity would have had a
chance
within their space cities they could
have protected themselves by hiding
amongst the gas giants
but even a photoid like the one which
took out the tricelerians could not
compare to the weapon sent into our
solar system
part 3
singer humanity had been warned that
this weapon would come
it was the final secret in tian ming's
fairy tales the only one which they had
not been able to fully decipher
the warning related to a dimension
strike
it was a distant world which had noticed
them
this mysterious distant and unimaginably
powerful alien world had long ago made
the decision to go on the offensive
and they had technology of a greater
magnitude than any humanity had ever
previously dreamed of
the world itself was currently engulfed
in a war between its homeworld and its
fringe world some undefined time earlier
the home world could not coexist with
the fringe world and one of the two
would have to be destroyed
we can discuss more details about this
civilization in future videos as they
are also heavily expanded upon in the
spin-off novel redemption of time
the lone individual named singer whose
task it was to watch the universe for
signs of intelligent life had been the
one to discover traces of humanity which
they named the star pluckers
first the other location had broadcast a
message via primitive membrane
the low entropy entities of that world
clumsily plucked their star
singer decided to call them the star
pluckers like the ancient bards of the
homeworld plucking the strings of the
rough country zither to send out their
message it was this message that
contained the self-decoding system
although the self-decoding system was
primitive and clumsy it was sufficient
to allow singer to see that a subsequent
message sent out by the dead 3-star
world followed the same encoding scheme
apparently an answer to the first
message sent out by the star pluckers
this was already inconceivable but after
that the star pluckers responded again
interesting
very interesting
singer had indeed heard of low entropy
worlds that possessed neither the hiding
gene nor the hiding instinct but this
was the first time he had seen one the
communications between humanity and
trisolaris had in fact been noticed all
the way back to the first time yawinji
responded to trisolaris but this alone
wasn't enough to reveal the location of
the worlds however it did reveal that
the distances between the two worlds
were very short this meant that if one
world was exposed the other world would
be as well and eventually humanity was
exposed
ultimately there was nothing they could
do to stop it even without singer some
other low entropy entity would have
noticed them
it was just a matter of time
or perhaps they had noticed them but
decided that a low entropy group that
didn't possess the hiding gene wasn't
much of a threat
and cleansing them was more trouble than
it was worth
but that would be a mistake a terrible
mistake broadly speaking if low entropy
entities like these star pluckers really
didn't have the hiding gene then they
would not be afraid of exposing their
own presence and they would expand and
attack without fear
at least until they got killed
however as applied to this particular
case the situation was more complicated
the first three communications were
followed nine time grains later by the
coordinate broadcast then 60 time grains
after that there was another long
membrane coordinate broadcast from
somewhere else pointing at the dead
three-star world
the chain of events painted an uneasy
picture
a picture that indicated danger
the cleansing against the dead 3 star
world had happened 12 time grains ago so
the star pluckers must have realized
that their own position had been
revealed their only choice was to shroud
themselves in slow fog so that they
would appear perfectly safe and no one
would bother them but they hadn't maybe
they didn't have the ability
singer is somewhat perplexed by the
actions of earth but nonetheless
recognizes the danger that they could
potentially possess
the potential danger is all that matters
in this circumstance
the only thing left was cleansing singer
took a mass dot out of the magazine
again
then realized that he couldn't use a
mass dot to cleanse the star pluckers
their planetary system had a different
structure than the dead world system it
possessed blind corners
using a mass dot might leave something
behind
thereby wasting effort he needed to use
a dual vector foil
as he continued to sing singer picked up
the dual vector foil with the force
field fueler and carelessly tossed it at
the star pluckers
singer had casually made the decision to
destroy our solar system because that
simply was their function
they were not an exceptional or
especially respected member of their own
civilization
nonetheless they were the destroyers of
ours
part 4
the deadliest weapon in the universe
humanity had been prepared for a mass
dot attack but the aliens had not sent a
photoid but instead they had sent
something infinitely more deadly
why aren't we entering jupiter's shadow
a a pointed to the combined city outside
the porthole
there's no point the bunker is useless
ciao bin said lowering his eyes how far
is the photoid from the sun zhongzin
asked
there is no photoid then what if you
found xiaobin gave a wretched laugh
a slip of paper
the dual vector foil when activated
would cause all matter it came into
contact with to collapse into a lower
dimension
only an object moving at light speed had
the potential to escape a dual vector
foil once activated
the advanced warning system had
discovered the unknown object sweeping
past the edge of the oort cloud at close
to the speed of light this was the first
time that humans within the solar system
had observed another alien civilization
other than the trisolarens the object
was not headed directly towards the sun
and it emitted weak gravitational waves
which was the only way they had been
able to detect it in the first place
when the projectile was about 150 au
from the sun the gravitational waves it
emitted began to rapidly decrease in
frequency the advanced warning system
discovered that this was due to its
deceleration within a few days the
projectile's velocity went from light
speed to 1 1000 of light speed and
continued to decrease such a low speed
meant that it wasn't enough to threaten
the sun
which provided further comfort in
addition at this speed human spacecraft
could keep up with it in other words it
was possible to send out ships to
intercept it
the object simply resembled a slip of
paper pure white surface slightly bigger
than a credit card
but so thin that its thickness could not
be measured
eventually the slip disappeared entirely
and began its deadly job
the entire solar system would be
compressed into two dimensions it could
not be stopped
close to a million people had escaped
europe six via the emergency exits
now caught by the three-dimensional
space around them collapsing into two
dimensions they fell toward the plane
like a swarm of ants caught in a
waterfall
a majestic reign of people fell onto the
plane and the two-dimensional human
figures in the city multiplied flattened
persons took up a lot of area though
still miniscule compared to the vast
two-dimensional buildings and resembled
tiny barely man-shaped marks in the
immense picture
the entire solar system would be
flattened this was the ultimate dark
forest attack
in my previous video the terrifying
mystery of the fourth dimension we
discuss the scene in death sindh where
the crew of blue space and gravity
encounter fragments of the fourth
dimension the tomb that they are able to
communicate with tells them that the sea
that is the fourth dimension was drying
but that the fish who had dried the sea
had gone to land before they had done it
land refers to the third dimension in
the chapter in death sindh that
introduces singer it is mentioned that
his entire species would soon transform
themselves somehow into two-dimensional
beings
as the homeworld decided to transform
into two dimensions singer asked
of course the elder already knew the
question
the elder did not answer which was also
an answer
if the rumor was true then it was a
great sorrow singer could not imagine
such a life
on the tower of values survival ranked
above all when survival was threatened
all low entropy entities could only pick
the lesser of two evils
this would be the only way to ensure the
survival of their species long term in
the universe because as i have stated in
other videos once a dimension strike
like the one that took place in the
human solar system begins it can never
be stopped and dimension strikes had
already been committed countless times
throughout the history of the third
dimension the third dimension was
disintegrating due to this fact and
eventually everything would collapse
into two dimensions it is implied that
singer's race may have once existed in
the fourth dimension and that they are
one of the races responsible for the
destruction of the fourth dimension
as the solar system collapses only
changing and the character aa are able
to escape the devastation
the technology developed by thomas wade
had continued to be worked on in secret
a single light-speed ship had been
created unbeknownst to the vast majority
of humanity
lulgie now extremely old chose to stay
behind among the last artifacts of
humanity on pluto he communicates with
xiang zhin and a.a as they exit the
solar system
chongzin knew that she had no choice but
to live on she and a.a were the last two
survivors of human civilization
her death would mean the death of half
of all that was left of humanity
living on was the appropriate punishment
for her mistake
but the course ahead was blank in her
heart space was no longer black but
colorless
what was the point of going anywhere
where should we go
xiangzi muttered
go find them
luji said his image was even more
blurred now and only black and white his
words illuminated shangzin's dark
thoughts like lightning she and a.a
looked at each other and immediately
understood who them meant luigi
continued
they're still alive the bunker world
received a gravitational wave
transmission from them five years ago it
was a short message and didn't explain
where they were halo will periodically
hail them with gravitational waves maybe
you'll find them maybe they'll find you
luigi's black and white image
disappeared as well but they could still
hear his voice he said one last thing
ah
it's time for me to go into the picture
safe travels children
shangzin and aa watched as the entire
solar system was compressed into a
two-dimensional picture of itself
the transmissions they received carried
the dying voices of all humanity
until slowly there was only silence luji
had suggested that xiangzin seek out the
members of blue space and gravity
but she would head in another direction
tianming before his brain left the earth
had gifted chongzin with the star
a gesture of love in his mind she knew
that tianming still existed out there
somewhere in the void
she would head for their star
s74390e2
and hope to find him there
like several times before in human
history mankind had been diluted into
very few individuals
whether or not the human race would
survive would depend on how well they
would be able to navigate and hide
within the dark forest
in future videos we will discuss the
galaxy era and beyond what becomes of
humanity in the end
do we encounter the remnants of the
tricelerians again
there's actually a lot more to explore
with this series
if you want more cool science fiction
videos like this one check out my
channel and make sure you like and
subscribe for more quinn's ideas
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the lie behind the star is launching
february 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]
you